from my own experience I came to this  country when I was younger right from  where from Senegal okay uh I did I've  did a lot of stuff right I've I've did  crazy stuff but when it was time for me  to get married I went back home went to  Senegal I went back to Senegal yeah I  found the right woman for me because I  knew what I saw from what I saw in this  country there is no chance for the women  in the school for the women in this  country there was no you wouldn't marry  a woman no country no oh there's there's  one percent chance right okay because  I'm not saying every woman that I meet  in the city on Friday night or Saturday  night all the same yeah